bootle cat podcast man we got a special
guest about to do his thing representing
Houston Texas what part of Houston you
from not Orange Texas Orange Texas okay
so where's that it's like on the
outskirt it takes I mean uh Houston okay
okay we just had uh that Mexican OT
who's from Bay City yeah which is like
Baytown how far is that that's like
everything's like an hour away I feel
like yeah yeah it's about an hour you're
out there enjoying the best strip clubs
in America and open carry and all that
what you got going on real quick before
we have you rap man plug your [__] real
quick you know man y'all can follow me
on all my platforms at I am young pool
that's
i-a-m-y-u-n-g-p-o-o-d-a and a whole lot
of big [__] man you know what I'm saying
I got singles I I got the single with a
boogie with the hoodie Angelica Villa
got this single with Fat Joe out you
know what I'm saying I'm just working
we've been working for chauffeur show
for a show any uh any projects on the
way project on the way man Vivid pitch
is on the way the birth of feng shui on
the way yeah I'm mean I don't have the
release dates just yet but like I say
man y'all tap in with all my socials and
you know what I mean and uh shout out
your social I know people might spell it
yeah I am young that's why u-n-g yeah I
am young poodle
y-u-n-g-p-o-o-d-a go tap in man let's
get right to it come on back in let's do
it let's go
I mean yeah rip DJ Screw R.I.P Big Pokey
one time for Texas man young poodle
yes sir
thank you
hey look
look hey [__] I be on Legend [__] even
when my haters at the best I still be on
better [__] we ain't even gotta question
it [__] who you think you better than
I'm a blessing sitting down from heaven
mixed with perfection overdosed on
Elegance we can see it all in my action
I feel like I'm already Platinum I am a
money magnet That's the Law of
Attraction why they was thinking of
another caption I was trapping hustling
habits Pinocchio ass [__] man I didn't
sold strings to the puppet master I
ain't worried about another rapper These
[__] Ain't on my mind I parasail
through the parallel These [__] Ain't
That Divine feng shui wave out the line
I might come through and part to see my
life a movie starring me [__] this the
best part to see they got hate all in
hidden places mad at me cause they
didn't make it the Choppers spit and
fill them up quick [__] this [__] is a
meal replacement I put bread on the
kitchen table I can't let a [__] come
and take it unless you wanna meet the
Undertaker well don't die for a bunch of
people underdog
[Music]
I appreciate you guys watching this
freestyle we got another one coming and
then another one and then another one
and they're all brought to you by our
good Folks at LRG clothing you already
know what it is LRG been keeping you fly
for years they got so much new fly gear
right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle's on the way
presented by LRG